انضم إلينا الآن من أه مدينة Q8 سيئة ألف
أستاذ التاريخ في جامعة Q8
شكرا جزيلا لانضمامك إلينا أم هناك
قلق كبير أليس هناك
دوليا من تصعيد أه
في هذا الصراع وأنت تعلم هل
بدأنا نرى ذلك  في الاحتجاجات
المظاهرات في دول مثل لبنان
والأردن التي بها هذه الكثافة
السكانية الفلسطينية الضخمة دعني أخبرك أن الاحتجاجات
ليست فقط في التجمعات السكانية الفلسطينية أه كبيرة
أه الأماكن التي
يتواجد فيها الفلسطينيون فهي من المحيط الأطلسي
إلى الخليج نراهم في الرباط  نراهم
في المنامة نراهم في الدوحة نراهم
في الكويت نراهم في جميع أنحاء
المنطقة وهم متحدون في
مطلب واحد إنهاء القصف الإسرائيلي
على غزة وإنهاء
الاحتلال الإسرائيلي هذا أمر بديهي
هؤلاء شعب  تحت الاحتلال
وهم يستحقون حياة كريمة مثل
أي شخص آخر في العالم. لم
أر مثل هذا الحجم من الاحتجاجات في
المنطقة منذ الربيع العربي والشيء
المثير للاهتمام هو أن الناس من جميع
مناحي الحياة هم الليبراليون المتحدون
والمحافظون الكبار والصغار
لتحقيق هذا الهدف المشترك، إذا أرادت إسرائيل
أن تعيش بسلام في هذه المنطقة، فإنها
بحاجة إلى التكيف مع هذه الرسائل ويجب أن
يكون حل الدولتين في مقدمة ومركز
موقفها، فمواصلة
تجريد الإله من إنسانيته وتهجير إيانس
ليس هو الحل الذي ذكرته.
الربيع العربي يتحدث الناس عن
إمكانية أن يكون هذا ربيعًا عربيًا ثانيًا
وانتفاضات في دول على سبيل
المثال مثل أه الأردن حيث يوجد
قدر كبير من القلق على
الفلسطينيين وهم قلقون من أن
حكومتهم ربما لا تظهر
نفس النوع  الدعم هو
أمر حساس للغاية، أليس كذلك بالنسبة للعديد من
هؤلاء القادة أه إظهار الدعم
للفلسطينيين ولكن أيضًا عندما يكون لديهم
علاقات قوية مع إسرائيل،
فهو أمر حساس بالفعل
ودعني أخبرك أه الحكومات
في جميع أنحاء المنطقة تختار  على
أصوات الناس الذين يصعدون
في خطابهم وكلما
استمرت إسرائيل في هذا الهجوم
المدعوم من الولايات المتحدة للأسف كلما
زاد أه اكتساب الكثير من
الزخم للتأكد من أنه أه
خطاب وسياساتها أيضًا  التغيير
تجاه إسرائيل هذا ليس هذا ليس
شيئًا يمكنك الاستمرار في
القيام به ولا يتعلق فقط
بالشعب الفلسطيني في غزة، إنها
قضية إنسانية إنها تتجاوز أه العرب
حقًا وهذا شيء
كان بمثابة نداء حاشد في جميع أنحاء العالم
وهذا  هو شيء
تحتاج الدول الأخرى في الغرب إلى الاستماع إليه،
ولا يمكن أن يظل الجنوب العالمي على الهامش
بعد الآن. من الواضح أن إسرائيل عانت من
هجوم مروع، ويجادلون بأن هذا
رد على حقهم في الدفاع عن
أنفسهم ولكن من المفترض أنك تقول
إن غزوًا بريًا  هو أسوأ
شيء يمكن أن يحدث في هذه
المرحلة، حيث يمكن أن يؤدي الغزو البري إلى
حرب إقليمية يمكن أن تدخل فيها أطراف أخرى في
المعركة، وقد يكون ذلك
تصعيدًا سيئًا كبيرًا لجميع الأطراف
المعنية، لا ينبغي إراقة الدماء
ويجب على الجميع إدانة هذا الغزو.  قتل
الفلسطينيين والإسرائيليين، نحن بحاجة إلى
السلام والأمن والازدهار
لجميع المعنيين ومحاولة
الاستمرار في سلسلة العنف هذه،
وهذه السلسلة من العنف لن
تنهي القصة، لقد قامت حماس
بعمل فظيع في الهجوم ولكن دعونا لا
ننسى  أن هذا أيضًا رد فعل على
الإذلال اليومي الذي
يتعرض له الفلسطينيون في الاحتلال وليس
لديهم أي قدر من التحرك في
حياتهم اليومية ويجب
تصحيح ذلك في أسرع وقت ممكن. ما مدى
قلقك من أن أمريكا
تفقد أخلاقياتها؟  أرض مرتفعة أم
تقف إلى جانب إسرائيل مع
التعبير أيضًا عن قدر كبير من القلق
بشأن الأزمة الإنسانية التي تتكشف أه
داخل غزة هل ستخسر أم بعض
التحالفات التي قد تكون لديها مع بعض
تلك الدول العربية التي تقف بشكل
أكثر ثباتًا معها  الفلسطينيون
هنا، تستنزف الولايات المتحدة كل ما تتمتع
به من مكانة جيدة في المنطقة.
جاء الرئيس بايدن قبل ساعات قليلة وقال إننا
بحاجة إلى أن نتذكر من نحن، وأعتقد أنه
يجب أن يكون هناك نهج حذر للغاية
لتحديد هويتهم
لأن أمريكا  التي نعرفها في
المنطقة هي دولة تهتم بالآخرين، وهي
دولة تتحدث عن بوتقة انصهار
في بلدها، وهي دولة تهتم
بالحريات والكرامة التي لا
تتم ترجمتها على أرض الواقع عندما يتعلق الأمر
بالصراع الفلسطيني الإسرائيلي كونه أحد  لن يساعد الطرف المتحيز
في النهوض حتى بقضية
الأمن القومي الإسرائيلي، إذا كانت هذه هي
العدسة المحدودة التي ينظرون
من خلالها، فهذا لن يساعد في النهوض
بالأمن القومي الأمريكي أيضًا، حسنًا،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك على الانضمام إلينا.  آل
آمنة في مدينة الكويت